[Music]
just mercy so just mercy stars Michael B
Jordan and Jamie Foxx Michael B Jordan
plays a young lawyer named Bryan
Stevenson he's young he's idealistic he
has hopes and dreams he's wants to help
people and for the plot of this movie
the main person he helps out as a man
named Walter McMillian Jamie Foxx plays
him he was wrongfully convicted of the
murder of a girl he's not just in jail
for it he's on death row Stephenson's
like is his tussin add up so we got to
get him out of there also not only is
this movie based on the true story
there's also based off of the book just
mercy written by Bryan Stevenson who's
the person Michael B Jordan portrays in
this movie all right out the gate we're
gonna give praise for the acting you
because Michael B Jordan and Jamie Foxx
crushes they're so good in this movie
and I feel like that's kind of a no-shit
scenario I mean we know they're good
they are good they're great even there
was a point around the movie rain
collateral I felt like Jamie Foxx was
just unstoppable at a point he became
one of those actors were if he's in a
crappy movie I generally speaking still
liked him in it but his performance in
this movie shows why Jamie Foxx is in
fact great it's an emotional performance
he has to play this guy who he's on the
razor's edge hope what is hope he's a
guy who was wrongfully convicted sent to
death row for something he did not do
all the evidence showed that he didn't
do it but not he's still there hope
seems like something that we just talked
someone in that scenario and he
absolutely does show and express that in
his performance also a movie with a very
important message which does not make
for a good movie I see that a lot people
are like well as a movie with a very
important message the movie that asks
these important questions and my next
phrase my next thought is always like
yeah but is it a good movie just mercy
is a movie with an important message
that is also a good movie other than the
great acting the finer details of what
they're uncovering that really does keep
you locked in to uncover one thing it
leads to another that want to interview
people it's interesting to see the
people that interview the people who
don't want to be interviewed us the
corruption wheels sex is one scene I got
to give props for this thing this is
scene without giving away too much as a
scene where someone dies and I have seen
thousands of people die in movies
whether they be made-up characters or
characters that are based off of real
people I've even seen a few go out this
way there was something about this it's
it's like I was experiencing ego death
like I was having a panic attack I felt
like I was in the room and it was really
uncomfortable which is the point it's
supposed to be uncomfort
but it's just it was that real so I
gotta give props for that I can't say
that about a lot of movies let alone a
lot of deaths in movies so that does
point to the fact this movie is
addressing important things and forcing
people to ask questions thankfully in a
movie that is also very good
interestingly enough more want to know
about what happened to the sheriff like
at the end of the movie it being based
on a true story they have the excerpts
with like alright this is what happened
with this person this person that person
but this movie and I assume the book is
clearly pointing a finger of corruption
towards the sheriff the sheriff the
department all of that what happened to
him any repercussions at all I'd like to
know I mean shoot I have the internet I
could look it up but I was actually
surprised that movie didn't address that
but in the end the movie is solid great
performances a little formulaic however
I also stress the movie is very
impactful you take it with you when you
leave the theater and I will say just
mercy is definitely worth watching and
definitely worth buying on blu-ray
alright so just mercy have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]